[Music]
stanford university
today's session is on investing in the
next generation of robotics cyber
security and enterprise i.t the session
is named because those are the three
focus areas that tj focuses on so
tj was previously a managing partner out
of utah currently general partner at
next 47 and he focuses on those three
areas that i highlighted when he was at
ink utel it was quite interesting
because that's the non-profit strategic
venture arm that operates on behalf of
the u.s intelligence committee and he
was leading a number of investments in
cyber security and data center
technologies a number of companies that
many of us have heard today since
they're listed on the public stock
market he invested on pre-ipo early on
and those include fire eye cloudera pure
storage and of course a number of other
investments we love that tj is a
stanford grad he did his mba at stanford
and also did an undergrad at university
of virginia so tj thanks for joining us
today i'll go over to some of the areas
we talked about robotics cyber security
and enterprise i.t and also sprinkle in
your investment experiences on that
front does that sound good
it sounds great thank you for the
invitation to join and i'm excited to
talk with everybody it's more fun for me
if there are people jumping in with
follow-up questions or counter opinions
even so please please do that along the
way
sounds great especially since i think
opinions around what to invest in always
varies from person to person starting
with robotics would love to hear more in
terms of how do you think about
investing in robotics companies and also
how do you define
and narrow that definition of what you
consider robotic autonomous driving has
seemed to be
the key target for a lot of investments
that vcs have made in robotics but do
you consider that for instance as part
of the definition for robotics and
actually sergey from the class had an
interesting question in which he asked
why is robotics
a disliked area for vcs so would love
your thoughts um on that as well
sure that's a great question and maybe
we can get off that one i think people
are afraid of areas where they've lost
money in the past and a lot of a lot of
investors in the past have been excited
about anything that's fun to talk about
at cocktail parties i'm going to express
a little bit of self-loathing for the
investment persona the real stars of all
this are always the entrepreneurs and
the technologists that are making these
new products people get excited about
cars things that fly or robots because
and from personal experience i know this
is it's more fun to talk to people about
those investments and it's certainly
just more inherently interesting than to
talk about database technology even
though there's more money spent on
database technology and it's easier to
create new companies around it but a lot
of people have lost money a few people
few investors have made money in
robotics with some significant counter
examples
and today especially most investors are
excited about software
and sas based businesses that have great
recurring revenue streams and great
margins
robotics companies because they're this
mixture of software and hardware we look
for ones that have all the ip and mostly
ip and software still have a typically
lower margin profile than a pure
software company
and there's some hard challenges that
they're working to address ernestine you
asked how do we define it what areas
that we look at in our autonomous
vehicles part of it certainly i'd put
autonomous vehicles as example of
robotics
and how do we automate
discrete systems that move so that that
goes from anything from the kind of
robot we've all imagined would be around
the house including ones we see like
roombas but into autonomous vehicles but
in less exquisite contexts into
purpose-built systems that operate
without humans driving them we could
have some in the portfolio that we can
talk about drones count robots that just
do one thing and do it very slowly not
around humans are some of my favorite
targets these days you think about one
of ours which is the avid bots a floor
cleaning robot
you take some of the same self-driving
technology that was that was developed
for autonomous vehicles and you apply it
to a system that instead of going 70
around a lot of other cars it's going 2
miles an hour
with no no people around weighs a lot
less it's got a lower lower bill of
materials
it's just a more tractable problem and
one that can go after a point economic
roi and that is really the final punch
line when we're looking at robotics
opportunities it's not just is the
technology great but does this address
uh identifiable pain point that
somebody's willing to pay for
and that's often
what's missed with what makes frontier
investing in frontier tech investing
dangerous is because
the technology can be so awesome and so
alluring that you forget or
neglect to square that with who's going
to pay for it i'd love to dive more into
specific applications and verticals of
robotics that do you produce that roi
that people are willing to pay for and
for me i i would consider it as there's
certain jobs that people and employers
naturally have trouble staffing even
during times of high employment and the
robotics can come in and solve those
problems and we love your thoughts in
terms of just thinking of a couple
verticals being like warehouse
automation fulfillment there is
obviously amazon's acquisition of kiva
that pushed that construction maybe
retail food agriculture the medical
field has seen a number of different
solutions that have been solved with
robotics what are some of these
verticals that are exciting for
investors to put money into and are
there ones that just don't really seem
viable like consumer electronics for
instance or what are your thoughts on
verticals that have high potential for
startups
yeah i like the framework of first is
there something that a robot can deliver
that is not possible today so improved
capabilities and i think a lot of
surgical or healthcare focused robotic
systems can fall into that category not
an area i know well or i've invested in
but there's been a good number of
success in that sector drone
applications of drones end up in that
bucket as well because you can enable uh
rate of inspection or leverage on human
workforces in in ways and collection of
new data that you couldn't get with
manual systems because you can get to
places and get there faster and you can
respond better than you could in the
past
the second thing i think of
if it's not about improving capabilities
but it's about cost replacement and
human augmentation or human staff
augmentation is what's the labor date
labor rate you are uh replacing
and
are there some sort of extreme
constraints either seasonally or
consistently that uh make it hard to
staff against your labor needs and so
interesting you mentioned warehouse
robotics those the warehouse
environments go through these crazy
seasonal swings where
even amazon takes everybody in the
company and sends them to the dc's to
help with fulfillment at the holiday
season robotics is clearly a great win
for spiky needs like that where you flat
out cannot hire enough people at certain
times of the year harder cases to make
and ones that i like to avoid are
where you don't have any of those
dynamics i don't know if anybody was
around when at the stanford mall there
was the melt was a
grilled cheese
a fast casual restaurant with
robotic grilled cheese machines
which is cool and you want to go get a
grilled cheese from the melt when it
exists and i think it raised a bunch of
money from sequoia but the labor rate
that you're replacing just isn't
compelling so how do you do can you
really afford to pay for really
expensive grilled cheese robots when
your alternative is a pretty low cost
labor
so we think about i think about
restaurants
in retail but especially restaurants in
that category ag because of the scale
and again lower labor rate at least
labor is a percent of the overall cost
structure often ends up in that category
too so the zod had a question um do you
want to jump in with your question cool
yeah i was just wondering like do you
think there will be like a technology
shift in the next few years in robotics
or is it like more like a continuous
trend that things are getting better i'm
mainly wondering because i feel like
deep reinforcement learning stuff are
relatively new in research in the past
few years so i'm wondering like will
there be like a gpt moment or something
like that or yeah or is it continuous
i think it is fairly continuous for most
robotic systems the all robotic systems
benefit from some of the same
advancements so slam so localization and
and path planning object recognition
these are giant leaps forward that we've
seen in the last 10 years from your
computer vision standpoint so their
robotic systems are benefiting from that
they also benefit from sensor
improvements and minor radar but i don't
see on the horizon a big leap forward
from there i think it's a lot of
distilling to practice
new tech that is is already accessible
what do you think is that
yeah it makes sense yeah i i just wonder
because i feel manipulation stuff are
still not as good as like motion and
like locomotion and stuff yeah but i'm
generally curious so at this area and
yeah one of the one of the things that
we've invested in the last year was a
system that's designed to help
uh
human operators of robotic systems in
industrial environments so these are
robotic arms that do operations at
cellular manufacturing primarily
reconfigure or retrain those systems
without having to call in an outside
expert
and so this is how do you become more
flexible as a manufacturing facility and
how do you avoid the cost and time of
those outside contractors
and that is some of the same aim so
flexibility and ability to retrain but
through a very
simple
approach which is to have a stylist that
teaches the robot what to do next and
how to do it in smart software
and that ends up being more accessible
in the near term than relying on the
cutting edge reinforcement learning yeah
it makes sense in that one case yeah
thanks for the question tj in terms of
challenges with robotics either from a
when you're thinking about it from an
investment standpoint either a
technology challenge or market or roi
sort of challenge are there certain
inverting holes that you would avoid
applications of robotics in
i
like to avoid things i don't know
anything about so i avoid healthcare and
surgical applications even though they
could be great investments i acknowledge
that
i also avoid ones that that
typically have a hard time adopting new
tech and so these are legacy markets
where the buying behavior is very
fragmented
a great example is construction
so
we've got a great investment in a
company that retrofits
excavators
to dig autonomously and that is civil
engineering and it's at a pretty big
scale it's great for trenching it's
great for foundation work but when you
get to the many different teams that are
building a building there are a bunch of
startups that are focused on helping
that process be more efficient there is
huge and identified need
for that but
no buying behavior that stands today
that really supports big significant
purchases and so we like to avoid that
kind of fragmentation in markets and
then i'd go back to ag and say it's not
for instance vertical farming was
extremely hot about five years ago a lot
of money went into vertical farming
and the
hardest part about that was both the
buying behavior but also the analog
risks associated with and the biological
risks associated with trying to automate
and have indoor farming because you can
have some contamination a little bit of
algal growth and then at all you've lost
the entire crop and that's not something
you can solve with software
typically
the civil engineer in our class has a
follow-up question or comment to your
point
yeah just as a follow-up you mentioned
the there's a ton of startups in the
construction industry focused on trying
to improve the efficiency of
construction but just not a lot of
buying going on in that market i was
just curious if you had any idea why or
if there are any other markets that are
notoriously stubborn and if there's a
particular reason or if it's just
construction in general that's the
outlier
it's a great question i i think any so
we can point uh we can point to many
industries where they're just massive
and they could definitely benefit from
improved tech but they're not used to
doing it so it's just gonna take a long
time for for that uptake so
construction's an example retail's an
example and we'll come across more ag i
think agg's got a good history of big
robotic systems like combines and gps
enabled rtk enabled tractors but at this
time ag falls in that same category i'd
say construction
we did we got really excited about some
entrepreneurs because they're they're
great teams and they had some good
products it was almost all software
based with just some easy to use optical
capture systems
and they're going to help contractors
and teams of contractors manage progress
against plan
create as builds you do all the things
that
you really want to do better and faster
as a big construction team which is
really a series of small teams
the challenge that we saw after talking
to big general contractors is that
each project is managed as a separate p
l a separate business and so there's
very limited centralized buying
of products
and therefore
on each project there are
about 60 different applications that are
purchased and built against the profit
of that project
and the amount of money that can go to
any one of those 60 apps
is constrained so i think what we're
looking for and someday this will change
is the team that cracks the code
on or just the general market shift
where there's centralized buying
every single project that a gc
undertakes
benefits from these these centralized
buys there have been great successes
playing grid is one
right so just planning and and bim but
for that intersection of software and
robotics we're still watching
do you see anything different
no i just
i i agree that it's just a weird problem
and i like your perspective on that it's
just fragmented into specific projects
where the bottom line is everything
and taking a risk and being the first
person on such a large expensive project
is dangerous because
there's just there's risk there and so i
think you've nailed that and i like that
perspective thank
you cool thanks
so we have a question from andrew as
well related to autonomous vehicles
and efforts on retrofitting vehicles
with autopilot i assume andrew feel free
to chime in but a lot of startups have
tried to tackle that problem first just
because going into full autonomy is very
challenging yes i feel like a slightly
broken record because this is just
something that i'm personally
intimately aware of because i've done it
to my car yeah yeah so it's a lot of fun
and so i was just curious to hear what
you have to say about it it's a great
question and if i hadn't
and so i know of a team that is pursuing
this there's a company called ghost
i think it's called ghost anyway it's a
retrofit system for existing cars to
become
uh level three level four autonomous
and the founder is the smartest engineer
i've ever met there's something
interesting there and i've learned a
long time ago not to discount this one
founder or the primary backer
who's mike spicer at sutter hill who is
probably the best investor in the world
today
all that said like the core questions
are people ready to
do this are there is there an
installation network that can be built
to do this retrofit
and
what are the
inherent limitations to performance and
you have this asymptote of performance
that is lower because it's a retrofit as
opposed to a unified system in most of
the cases where we've looked at
autonomous
robotics you benefit greatly from having
the whole system really tightly
integrated because you know exactly
where
the sensors are
you can optimize processing and power
draw for the onboard slam and path
planning you need to do so it becomes a
bigger challenge if you have to
calibrate for each system that you're
applying onto
i guess that one interesting thought
experiment is
how accessible the build materials
of the system you did would be for the
mass market and whether you could do it
on the cheap because i've seen actually
a lot of the the early self-driving car
startups
everybody would use ford fusions because
they were drive by wire more than other
cars
and some would just use in a really
impressive way just webcams so there was
one called auto x that was just webcams
and i remember going on a drive around
sunnyvale
and
it did a great job
and it just had you sit in the back seat
and you'd see it stop at stop signs and
make turns and avoid traffic and then
your back would start sweating because
there was so many
cpus uh or so many servers crammed in
the trunk you know it's just hoovering
up all the onboard energy and and not
the type of thing that works technically
but doesn't scale so well to the mass
market
yeah the the system i have is like
much further in its infancy compared to
that it's quite simple it's just some
heavily modified android phone just when
like a 3d printed casing that's like
just glued to the windshield and then
the car like already has some
pre-existing interfaces to like turn the
steering wheel like with the lane keep
assist features that you'll find
standard on like most new toyotas that
gives you so many way to turn but it's
not enough torque to like
really turn the car like a lot so it
won't probably won't be taking turns
stock but it's interesting it's it it
certainly can't fully drive itself yet
super cruise technology like a package
that you'd see on a lot of oem cars it's
fairly similar yeah probably a little
better probably comparable to what tesla
has right now
that's awesome that's impressive
and it's not very expensive to have an
android phone in a
onboard chat yeah no no definitely not
it's uh definitely manageable so
cool
josie has a question around remote
assistance system as well
jesse do you want to jump in with your
question yeah i can do that my question
was just how you invest in remote
assistance systems and whether that kind
of falls under robotics and how those
companies are seen or evaluated given
that like the ultimate goal of most of
the robotic systems or supporting is to
minimize any of that human like touch
and can you help me with an example of a
remote assistance system i just don't
know
yeah yeah so i actually worked at amazon
for a couple of years before coming to
stanford it was a robotics program
called amazon scouts like a robot that
drives on the sidewalk to deliver
packages and one of the ways that we
actually accelerated our operations when
like the autonomy was not quite working
or
had some gaps basically was that you
have remote human
monitors that can take over when the
robot is confused i think there are
companies that have done this in
autonomous like self-driving cars as
well or trucks but it's more about like
the final steps in your self-driving
process like a human
uh in the loop to help you navigate the
parking lot or something like that but i
imagine there's other i think in
healthcare as well there's it's more of
a human working with the robot but i
imagine there's always this force that's
trying to get the robot to do more and
more of the work
yeah it's interesting because there were
a couple startups that were focused on
we're not going to make an autonomous
truck we're just going to make a truck
that can be teleoperated really well and
the big challenge that we saw was that
if you're planning to do teleoperation
consistently for an autonomous vehicle
then you need
something like 250 millisecond latency
which is right at the edge of really
strong cell coverage
and you don't want to count on that if
you're trying to drive all over the
country so there was a connectivity
challenge there the other form we see is
exception handling which is i think what
you described at amazon which is a slam
dunk great way to get
around things that will pop up
in any deployment that are hard to
address or hard to predict
and we've got that with some of the
products that we've invested in where
it's a team of humans that says okay
this there are 300 robots out there
we're a team of 10
and we'll get alerts every once in a
while that one is stuck because somebody
uh blocked it in a weird way and it
needs to understand the path around it
because it's never dealt with this
before
the only challenge there
is
that
whatever you end up constructing in
terms of that team it's inherent
overhead and so it just hits your gross
margin
but it can be a great either medium or
long term if you can scale it
effectively approach to handling these
exceptions tj i do want to touch upon
one other question with regards to
robotics before we move on to
cybersecurity and enterprise i t just
limited on time which is this past year
has definitely been interesting with the
rise of stack financing so we've seen a
lot of liquidity available for investors
and robotics companies with zaps and the
whole idea of for the class special
purpose acquisition companies and plague
check companies where it's been a way
for a lot of companies to
avoid the traditional ipo process but
still go public because this blank check
company acquires the private companies
personally i think it's been an
interesting opportunity for some of the
hardware intensive companies to get
faster access to large amounts of
capital that can fund product
development over several years but tj
would love your thoughts in terms of
facts over the past year especially and
how this affects someone who might be
looking to start a robotics company
yeah it's a question of the day and it's
i love everybody's thoughts if i guess
we have a lot of time together
we'll go run around on this one it's an
amazing trend this is the amount of
money that's been vectored via specs to
startups that are pre-revenue or just
into the revenue growth
has been profound and it's been a really
compelling low cost of capital for a lot
of these companies
the
question in my mind is can you count on
it being there in another year or two or
three
and i'm not convinced you can and it's i
was just talking with a team that we
work with and
they just raised a hundred million
dollars and then
are thinking maybe down the road the
next round will be a spec
because we have access to even more
money and it'll be even lower dilution
and i think where we came out was we all
agreed that specs
nine to 12 months from now will either
be
significantly more legitimate because
there'll have been the success cases
that have started to ramp revenue and
have demonstrated that they were not
incredibly risky and probably riskier
than any of the investors really
understood or they'll be a lot less less
legitimate
and a lot of the specs will get beaten
up in the markets and the sec will come
down hard on them
we've seen that in the last few weeks
where the sec has removed some of the
safe harbors and removed some of the
potential for these companies to make
forward-looking claims that are really
aggressive and dno insurance is almost
impossible to get if you're on the board
of a spag
so i think that's strained right now i'm
hopeful that there are success cases it
has been a profound trend an amazing
thing that i couldn't have predicted
everyone was quite scared with once
covet hit and everything started
shutting down that we all had to extend
cash reserves for portfolio companies
and then all of a sudden all these ipos
were happening and then the stock market
bounces back up with without even
without pre-vaccine days so it's just
the the insane amount of capital
availability yeah it means that you can
get access
if you have the profile that investors
either public or venture investors get
excited about you've got endless access
to capital and it's on the order of
hundreds of millions of dollars whenever
you want it
and it's something i've never seen
before it's amazing for the sake of time
would love to dive into cyber security
obviously a space that you spent a lot
of time in both at next 47 as well as
previously i think you tell what is your
general investment thesis on investing
in cyber security companies
yeah it's interesting because it's it's
one of these things that's it's there's
always opportunity it is always a
derivative of new compute environments
and in new ways in which people use
systems
and anytime you make a shift in how you
use compute or systems then there are
new vulnerabilities that pop up and then
those vulnerabilities lead to new
products
and those new products
can give companies initial escape
velocity the hard part is what i believe
the
long-standing truism that to be a big
company in cyber you have to be a
multi-product company
and so that initial product has to be
the starting point you have to be able
to draw a line from that initial product
to several products the other thing that
we really like to see is
going after existing buckets of budget
dollars because trying to convince
the world that they need a new type of
cyber security and i think an example i
think of is 10 or 12 deception networks
startups that were around i was very
excited about and have run their course
in the last five years versus the next
great firewall company or endpoint
company
where there's already tens of billions
of dollars to spend in that sector
ready to go from all the legacy provider
to
to a new startup
and it's just a much easier sales motion
if we can dive into a specific example
an investment that you made while at a
utah firearm obviously a well-known
cybersecurity company nowadays but what
drove you to invest in that company and
as you answer that would love for you to
also address zach's question which is
given that utah is affiliated with the
government the incentives are different
for investing in
fire eye versus if you're a traditional
venture fund investing on behalf of lp's
purely motivated by returns for example
yeah i would love to and i've lived both
sides of it so i'd love to comment on
that a little bit i think fireeye really
is is a
an extra sweet spot in cyber investing
and that is
uh use of a new technology to secure
systems as opposed to a new system to
secure a new technology the distinction
i'll make is when hypervisors emerge
there were a lot of startups that said
hey we're going to secure the hypervisor
fireeye said we're not going to secure
the hypervisor we're going to use
hypervisors to secure systems and so
they in essence they use lightweight
virtual machines that became this
concept of sandboxes that allowed you to
have a dual trigger approach to
determining whether
traffic coming into your network was
malicious and that greatly reduced false
positives and allowed them to sell a ton
of their systems and and deliver a lot
of value to customers so i like that if
you can identify now it's containers or
serverless functions lambda functions if
you can if if you a talented team or
investor can identify companies that use
those new technologies to improve
security it's better i think with better
upside than
to find ways to secure those new
technologies the difference between
inkytel and
other investors inquitel is designed to
provide access
really a bridge between hard to reach
customers in the intelligence community
and new technologies
and so it needs to configure itself for
access
not for
having big stakes in the companies it
invests in and not for management
not for optimizing financial return
so ink utel is partially dilutive
capital it delivers revenue and it
delivers customer insight
and represents and then in the good
cases a call option into growing
presence in the federal market with
these hard to reach customers down the
road so a great point of leverage for
the companies it works with it trades
that for again uh amount of a cap table
that it looks to acquire because it does
not want to compete with all the other
traditional investors out there
because it needs that access
and it trades it for speed because it
wants to characterize end user interest
and exactly what they'd want to see out
of a product before making investment in
most cases
and i compare that to where i am now and
we're growing next 47 as a traditional
fund one lp but
operating at speed so we will sometimes
have a first meeting with the company
if it's in the sector we know then we're
running a term sheet in three days and
that could be a term sheet where we're
trying to invest 40 50 million dollars
that's nothing special that's what every
investor does these days and it is a
just a different cycle
to a different end and question from
jason is how do companies and
entrepreneurs generally perceive
a fund like inkytel being
government-backed versus something
that's more of a traditional venture
fund and i think one thing that's
interesting is um obviously in my mind
the hotel has definitely built this
great reputation over the last few years
but curious tj from your experience
pre-fire idea pre some of these really
notable investments that inkytel made
what was it like convincing
entrepreneurs to take money from intel
compared to another venture fund you
know it was it took time for guitar to
be viewed as a valid partner and when
something
is done over and over again with enough
co-investors in a tighten up geography
so especially around the bay area then
people get to know that
it's nothing it's something to be
embraced because the there is value
conveyed and that's in in customer
insight and then and in revenue
and so we had to go through a lot of
those cycles to build the reputation
again we're not competing with investors
and that helped or inkytail i still say
we sometimes use those five years ago
that helped a lot that we were all
pulling the same direction both
companies investors and inquito
so
recently been all over the news two
state sponsored hacks on the us one was
the russian cyber espionage campaign
known as solarwinds that compromised
nine federal agencies and about 100
private companies and the other was the
chinese hack of microsoft exchange
servers would love your thoughts in
terms of can you share what exactly
happened during these attacks how do we
think about preventing these attacks
from happening and
more broadly what are some cyber
security trends
that we should think about that
investors vcs should
put money into given these sorts of
attacks that are happening with greater
frequency
yeah it's interesting that i won't go
super deep on either of them because i'm
not i'm not super deeply either but the
there are vast differences between the
two so the chinese
backed attack against exchange servers
there's something like 30 000 different
servers were compromised and that
allowed for likely capabilities
backdoors installed that could very
least monitor communications within
those servers that were compromised and
potentially migrate into other systems
connected systems so very significant
the thing you gotta wonder about there
and maybe you have an opinion ernestine
or anybody on this call is why would you
do that
because 30 000 servers is not subtle
right and it's not targeted
and it's going to be it's going to be
discovered
pretty quickly and it's going to be a
giant headache to clean up but it's not
something that's clandestine and to me
that's maybe trying to make a statement
or maybe
a mistake something was released in a or
maybe it's a you know semi party
that was not managed effectively
on the solar winds attack this was a
pretty specific splendid attack where
software that was going to be used by
other systems was compromised
and then that allowed for future
compromise of the companies that had
deployed it
seemed pretty brilliant pretty very
sophisticated and it took some of the
best security researchers in the world
to figure that one out and it was
targeted enough or at least could be
used in targeted way that i think was
very significant the the two attacks to
me it's like
one's a great ad for office 365. maybe
nobody wants an on-premise exchange
server anymore and for
cloud-based security the other one
i don't know i don't know how companies
end up changing what they do i think it
leads to probably shift left security
and products that help developers make
sure that what they're doing is reviewed
and highly secure so there's probably
some momentum there
what's funny to me is
big seemingly nation states
state-sponsored attacks like this
in my experience don't move the market
and buying behavior of corporations that
much
and i think that at least in the u.s
they rightfully assume that the defense
against these nations state attacks is
really the domain of the government
and of organizations that have special
authorities to to do that to conduct
that defense
where things really people really start
paying attention is when
techniques and tactics refined by these
early attacks transition into money
making mode
and so we saw that with botnet cycle on
the
2010 time frame we're seeing that with
all the ransomware work right now
and when
criminals are using
new techniques to make money or to
disrupt systems
then new products people are spending
money on new products in a huge way
so i think we're going to see continued
ramp and cyberspend and people are
always going to be asking how any new
product is going to help them defeat
uh ransomware these days or anything
else
i was just thinking it's quite
interesting that even just the attack
that happened about a day ago that i
neglected that she mentioned was also
around hackers shutting down pipelines
and when you are a fun trying to focus
on cyber security as an investment
thesis it does seem that sometimes these
attacks don't actually allow you to get
more money from lps it's not necessarily
a correlation as you mentioned between
increase in a tax
directly tied to more investment dollars
being put into the sector yeah the other
funny footnote to the pipeline attack
was the attackers posting the mia culpa
saying hey we we didn't mean to attack
the pipeline really sorry
this one kind of got out of hand which
is funny and who knows
anyway ashley i know you have a question
do you want to chime in with that sure
just
a question like there are just a
proliferation of cyber security
companies and i just wanted to ask like
i'm a newbie in in the space and i just
i'm just curious like what
differentiates like some of the
companies from others like
what are like the biggest challenges
these companies have i think it's that
the
the answered it which is awesome and
that is the differentiation is the big
challenge because there are so many and
you go to rsa and and every year it gets
twice as big as the prior year and the
marketing company copy from half the
company is all identical and so you're
like how do you actually make how do you
make inroads with customers and convince
them that you're something special
so that's i think that's the hardest
thing
the that differentiation is is really
the the biggest challenge marketing and
go to market become really difficult
there's this maslov's hierarchy of what
do people want to spend money on so
first they want to spend money on things
that make them more money so increase
revenue second it's things that reduce
costs so make them more profit
and then third is avoid risk and most
cyber security products are down here at
the bottom luckily for the sector
there's a lot of fear here and execs
have lost their job because of
compromises and so there's 100 billion
dollars a year spent down here so
nothing to see at but it can be hard to
shake lose the buying cycle at the
bottom sometimes
some of the best cyber security
companies in the last 20 years are ones
that actually combine
number two and number three so they end
up delivering great cyber security but
they're selling to people that just want
to use them to make their lives better
increase efficiency these are things
like tanium or going even farther back
big fix which was a patch management
product
so software needs to be updated with
patches often because vulnerabilities
are
discovered and if you don't patch it
then you're compromised in the future
bigfix was just hey it leads we're going
to make your life better by automating
what used to be a really painfully
manual thing to do
and
that improved security to no end but it
wasn't
improved security wasn't why people were
buying it it was because it
it made them
much happier now they did their daily
job and made them more efficient did
that answer your question i was riffing
on a few random threads there yeah i
might ask a follow-up on that so i was
also curious how important it is
that this cyber security software or
systems are compatible to the legacy
systems that companies use if they're
selling these products to enterprises
and is it fine that like
companies are more open to use like a
standalone cybersecurity product that's
new in the market or like the threshold
or the entry bar is high
you
almost all cyber security companies have
to create a whole bunch of integrations
with other cyber security vendors so
there's there are sims which are
security event management products which
are designed to be a landing point for
all sorts of data and alerts from other
systems so you have to first have to
integrate with them often you have to
integrate with firewalls
and it becomes a big capital sync for
any atscale startup the one exception
and this is a standout success in the
last five years is zscaler which said
we're going to make life for smbs
especially easier by just making
cybersecurity easy to easy to acquire
and deploy
you're not going to have to do anything
on-prem it's all going to be hosted and
you just point all your traffic to
z-scaler and we'll take care of the rest
it made no claim to having the best
firewall the best ids for the best
endpoint but it was the easiest to use
and it has been an incredible tear and
it's just an incredible success story so
you can also you can compete via better
technology and better efficacy or you
can just make it all easier to use and
win
often twice as much in this way versus
this way
yep
so tj we have about 15 minutes left so i
do want to touch upon enterprise ign
what do you look for when investing in
enterprise startups and how do you
decide on where to put your money in and
i think even just the example that you
gave with zscaler is hints a little bit
upon that in terms of there's different
ways that startups can succeed and
grow in revenue and i would love for you
to rift on that a little bit more
yeah we're all we all kind of get locked
in based on our own experiences i've
seen success in the past from teams that
take a clean sheet approach
to
again standing buckets to spend and pure
storage was a good example because it
said hey we can take consumer flash and
apply for the enterprise use cases in
ways that existing storage vendors
really can't do because they've got this
entire legacy stack of software that's
written for spinning disk and so a clean
sheet approach meant a better product
more usability and a funny story about
pure was that it it had a design
criteria for its first product that said
our installation manual needs to be
printed on a business card
and they migrated off it a bit and made
it both sides of the business card but
it was that ease of use that hadn't
really never been seen in enterprise
storage before that so impressive and
made people
happy to deploy their systems
and we see in the same approach you can
imagine how much easier it is to deliver
that kind of easy use in cloud systems
but we've invested against other
primarily on-prem systems recently it's
a little counter-trend but we're seeing
great success since the majority of
spend and i t is still not in cloud
these are systems like database systems
more storage that's taking advantage of
new memory types and new compression
approaches and then again we're looking
at the we're looking at how you extend
enterprise id to cloud effectively then
we get back into the cyber security on
when we think about that so tj i was
wondering if you have any opinions on
shifts that we've seen and how
organizations buy enterprise technology
today and if i'm a founder thinking
about starting an enterprise i.t company
how should i really capitalize on those
shifts
if there are anything yeah i know it's
dramatic and every rfp is either the
company is determined to shift the
workload to the cloud
or they're considering it so you need to
be ready to compete on that or to offer
just to host a solution the second thing
that we've been watching and we've
really seen the momentum flip in the
last few years probably isn't news to
anybody
almost every organization is ready to to
buy on a subscription model and
sometimes you'll get the sense that yeah
really they'd prefer perpetual with an o
m stream
and that's just doesn't seem to be the
case anymore
everybody's ready for subscription if
you just push them in that in that
direction and all investors care about
is seeing recurring revenue so that
becomes pretty critical for future
fundraising and for growing the business
long term so when you invested in
cloudera at incutel what made you decide
to do that investment
you know finally i had a bunch of really
knocked out arguments with people about
whether
the government agencies that we work
with
had any big data and that was in
retrospect ironic because these are big
data-driven organizations everybody's
got a lot of data these days right
cloudera was interesting because it was
different from
existing approaches so getting back a
little bit to that clean sheet approach
to a standing challenge we had just gone
through
several years of mostly parallel
relational databases so these are like
astra data tara green plum par excel
which is now red shift at amazon and all
of them were good products but very much
the same thing which was a
smart approach to sharding postgres in
ways that took away some of the pain of
sharding
cloudera and the nosql trend around
hadoop and there is no sql territory or
a sector was all about how do you change
how data's stored and how do you do late
binding a schema to a giant data lake
and so the fact that it was so different
made us believe that it had a good
amount of runway and could be useful and
not for everything you know not for
highly performant databases but for the
kind of
giant data lakes the
big organizations we're going to have in
the future
and how do you assign evaluation to an
enterprise i.t company versus
other companies since a lot of investors
will use a fairly specific mathematical
formula for that
yeah and we try to get early enough
where it
isn't it isn't as tied to comps it's
more an understanding of just how big
the market is and whether the company
has the unique approach to to build
something very special
all of these comps are being rewritten
right now and snowflakes the high-water
mark uh but there'll be another one in
the future that will
will be just a you know
profound shift in in how investors want
to value companies to me it makes it
nicer to get
pre-revenue when we get going with a
company or early revenue
because
the multiple expansion in the last year
especially has gone from something like
let's value a company based on
10 times forward recurring earnings
to
or revenue to 40 or 50. and so the
market comp now is in a lot of cases in
that 40 to 50 range
or far higher depending on whether
you've got particular lunacy in the bid
from other investors so i can't pretend
there's a ton of logic there ernestine
but i just say that the public market
valuations
ultimately drive it and for people that
invested
in snowflake at 9 or 10 billion that's
paid off really well and then everybody
else has that in mind as they're trying
to get into the next snowflake
yeah definitely different than a
robotics investment for instance yeah
what are other technology trends do you
um see as what would you put your
dollars into beyond robotic cyber
security and enterprise id it's it's
smart applications of ai and ml we
talked a little bit it was what can we
do with i
actually had asked this
about applications of reinforcement
learning deep learning there are good
good
places to take it today and it just
makes for great software great
applications and so anytime you can
deliver value to
companies through this big step forward
and application functionality i think
it's a good bet
any tech trends that you think are just
over hyped and should not be worth
investing in commercial space is a
dangerous area it goes back to who
doesn't want to talk to their friends
about how they invested in a rocket
company spacex rocket lab
notwithstanding there are too many
rocket companies out there and
very few exits to date in any form of
commercial space
so i i think they're gonna be a lot of a
lot of sunk dollars there
until all the spat companies um just buy
them because they have a two-year
timeline to spend their money or return
i think you're right yeah that's the
amazing thing about spaxx is that
ticking clock
and then and then our investment theses
just get flipped on its head again and
we think we should invest in space
companies now but i do agree that i
think that the applications for space
are pretty far off especially if you
think about it from a traditional
revenue and growth standpoint i would
love to finally touch upon some of your
really interesting
work more on the non-profit side and
specifically the work that you've done
with institute for security and
technology and would love for you to
just describe at a high level what is
the work that you do with them and why
is this important i think it's very rare
to see a lot of private for-profit
investors also focused on policy and
technology and i've always found that to
be a pretty unique angle that you've
taken
thanks yeah um i'm a huge believer and
what his institute for security
technology is all about it's a startup
itself and is if i think about the
analog to money making a for-profit
startup it's probably in the series b
series c range has done a ton it's
created a great first create a great
early product it's probably a great team
it's seen a lot of of great traction
recently and has driven a lot of value
most recently it had a
90 page report that came out where it
was managing a task force around
ransomware and it made a lot of pretty
interesting policy recommendations it's
worth checking out if anybody's
interested in that topic this is a team
that wants to recast what it means to be
a think tank and to drive to action and
drive to impact in a very authentically
west coast way so being very tech
centric intersecting with big tech
companies in addition to
information consumers in the government
and the core value prop the core need
that this team's identified
is that the pace of technological change
is only accelerating we've known that
for a long time as technologies emerge
and the world changes
there are both opportunities but also
threats from those new technologies that
people need to think of they need to
think of beyond the open market context
so policy becomes important
understanding becomes important so that
we don't do things to stifle
technologies but also don't expose
the world to risks from new technologies
i especially like that that isd thinks
in a global context it's not
institute for the u.s technology uh
security and security technology it's
really what does the world need to do to
think about
what does it mean for
us to apply
modern technology to nuclear commander
control or cyber security one
interesting thing that came out of the
cyber security task force report was
should it be illegal kind of in like a
foreign corrupt
practices act way for a victim of
ransomware to pay any ransom
and that's pretty provocative i think a
lot of people have probably talked about
that but why it all holds water until
you're the one that's been affected so
anyway i think that they're doing great
work i'm on the board and so i take
little claim for any of the great work
but i help them where i can and they
operate as a pretty effective non-profit
and one that if if you have any standing
anybody has any standing interest in it
i'm sure they'd love to
have more people in the ecosystem that
want to participate
thanks for sharing that final question
i'm going to pull this question from
something that spencer was curious about
in terms of as you progressed in your
career what prompted different shifts in
terms of for instance leaving bcg to go
to ink utel leaving utah to go to next
47 and any general career advice on that
front
nobody wants to know why i left enron
maybe that as well
i was lucky enough to get into grad
school and i left enron to come to
california and then everything at the
fan and i learned all the hard lessons
from that i left bcg it was a fantastic
experience learned a ton never wanted to
do it again
and i wasn't all that good at it and
what i really want to do is work with
early stage tech startups and i was
pretty sure it was being an operational
role inc utel was an opportunity that i
really latched on to because i wanted to
give back to the intelligence community
and i figured i'd be there for two years
maybe three years and then go into one
of these operational roles and i was not
at all attracted to the investment job
description i had met some investors
business school classes and wasn't very
impressed frankly and so
not really knowing what the job
description is all about not
understanding things i had this negative
opinion ankita was a fantastic 10 years
and it allowed me to feel like i made a
contribution learn a lot about startups
and just more anything i have the
pleasure of working with some great
teams that were building really
impactful products and i agree to like
the investment role
and that was after i really understood
what it was all about and then after 10
years i felt like it was time to
shift gears and invest for
financial return and had an opportunity
to try to grow a new firm along with a
couple of partners
and significant standing resources which
is next 47 so that was a great
opportunity